what i'm hoping to explore in this video
is the notion of a sample space
and it's a pretty hopefully you'll find
straightforward idea if you're having a
if you're doing a trial a rant uh
something that is probabilistic a trial
or an experiment a sample space is just
all of the it's the set of the possible
outcomes so a very simple trial might be
a coin flip
so if you're talking about a coin
well then the sample space is going to
be the set of all the possible outcomes
so you could get a heads or
you could you could get a tails that
right over here is the sample space for
the coin flip
so and it's very useful because for
example if these are equally likely
outcomes then and you say well what's
the probability of the event of a heads
you say okay that's one out of the two
equally likely outcomes or you can even
construct once you know all the possible
outcomes even if they aren't equally
likely you could say well let's create a
probability distribution we at least
know what the sample space is we know
what the possible outcomes are now let's
think about the probability of each of
those outcomes but a lot of times when
people talk about sample spaces they're
often they're they're they tend to be
most useful i would say when you have
equally likely outcomes like in the in
the case of a fair coin flip because
then from the sample space it's fairly
straightforward to think about the
probability of various events but this
is a simple sample space right over here
but let's make things a little bit more
interesting
let's imagine a world so let's just put
this aside a little bit
let's imagine a world where there's a
bakery and at that bakery
there are three types three flavors of
cupcakes but there's also three
different sizes of cupcakes so now we're
we're essentially looking at two
different ways in which the thing that
we're we're going to be sampling can
vary so what we're doing or let me write
this down so we have our flavors
flavors of cupcakes at this bakery and
let's say that you have chocolate
chocolate
you have let's say there's strawberry
strawberry
and let's say that there is vanilla
there is vanilla and it comes in they
come in three different sizes
so sizes
sizes could be small
so i'll just write it out small
medium
or large
so if you were and let's say you know
each of these flavors come in each of
these sizes or you can view the other
way around each of these sizes come in
all three flavors
so now how do you construct the sample
space if you say look i'm going to go
you know i'm going to blindfold myself
and walk into this bakery and and
randomly you know
somehow pick up a cupcake and you know
my fingers can't tell the flavor or the
size of the cupcake what are the
possible what are the possible outcomes
for the cupcake i'll pick and the
outcome would be both the flavor and the
size of the cupcake
well there's a bunch of ways to think
about this one way is you could draw a
tree
you could say okay well i'm gonna pick
three different flavors i could either
pick chocolate
chocolate
i'm going to pick strawberry
strawberry or i'm going to pick vanilla
vanilla
and then for each of those flavors i'm
going to pick a small medium or large
so you could say small
medium
large
small and so this is a small chocolate
this is a medium chocolate this is a
large chocolate this is a small
strawberry
medium strawberry
large strawberry this is a small vanilla
medium vanilla
large vanilla and so you see there's
nine possible outcomes once again this
is a medium chocolate you picked a
chocolate and it was a medium one this
is a large vanilla you picked a vanilla
and it is a large one and you could have
done it the other way around you could
have said well okay i'm going to either
pick a small
medium or large and then for each of
those i'm going to pick either a
chocolate strawberry or vanilla and i'll
just use the first letters to so i'm
either going to pick a chocolate a
strawberry or a vanilla when i write the
s over here in this magenta color i'm
talking about the flavor and if i write
the s in green i'm talking about small
so here you
you could have if you have a medium
cupcake it could be chocolate it could
be strawberry or it could be vanilla if
you have a large cupcake it could be
chocolate
strawberry
or
or vanilla so for example this was a
medium chocolate cupcake
over here a medium chocolate cupcake is
this one it's medium chocolate
it would be that one over here so you
could use these
a tree diagram like this to think about
the sample space to think about the nine
possible outcomes here but you could
also you could also do a i guess you
could say a grid or you could write
the flavors so you could have chocolate
chocolate
actually let me just write that well let
me write them out
actually let me just let me just write
the letters it's going to take a long
time to do so you can have the flavors
chocolate strawberry vanilla so that's
along that axis and then you have your
sizes you could have a small
a medium
or large and you can set up a grid here
so
this is another way to do it and notice
this grid has nine boxes
so let's look at it
so
set up the grid
set up the grid and so what is this one
going to be this is a small chocolate
small
chocolate
chocolate what is this one this is going
to be a small
a small strawberry
a small
strawberry and you could just keep
constructing like this where everything
in this row there's all about small
whoops
this is
small
i'm having trouble changing colors all
right
there is a small and then this is a
small
this is a small vanilla this color
changing is really
that's a difficult thing
small vanilla and all of these these are
all this would be a medium chocolate
medium strawberry medium vanilla
large chocolate large strawberry large
vanilla and once again you have nine
outcomes this is another way to think
about all of the possible outcomes when
you're looking at these two ways in
which our my cupcakes could vary another
way a third way that you could do is you
could literally just construct a table
well you could say okay
i could have a
chocolate actually i'm going to use the
letters again so let's say
we make this is the flavor
column
and then this is the size column
size column and so you could say i could
have a chocolate
that is
so let's see there's three types of
chocolate that i could have
there and they could be
they could be small
medium or large you could say there is
three types of
three types of strawberry it could be
small medium or large so let me write
that in
small
medium large or you could say well
there's three types of vanilla
there's three types of
color changing again three types of
vanilla once again it could be small
medium or large so you have these nine
possibilities now
the sample space the sample space isn't
telling you if they're equally likely or
not it's just telling you if you're
going to do an experiment what are all
the different possibilities the possible
outcomes for that experiment now in the
case where they are equally likely it
can be very very useful because you can
say you could do something like if you
said that okay it's equally likely to
pick any one of these nine outcomes you
could say well what's the probability of
what's the probability of getting a
something that is either small or
chocolate and so you can see well how
many of those events out of the total
actually meet that constraint but we'll
do more of that in future videos that's
just a little bit of a of a clue of why
we even care about things like sample
spaces especially sample spaces like
this where we're looking along two ways
or multiple ways that something can vary
and these types of sample spaces in
particular are called compound sample
spaces so these right over here this is
a compound
sample space because we're looking at
two different ways that it can vary not
just to heads or tails can vary by size
or by flavor and you can even have
compound
sample spaces that vary in more than two
ways